On June 5th the Washington DC Mayor
unveiled a statement painted down the
street leading to the White House black
lives matter
within 24 hours black lives matter
activists responded with their own
message defund the police this slogan
caught on rapidly among tens of
thousands of people protesting police
brutality in the United States but what
does it really mean to defund the police
and what if it's not as radical as it
sounds
[Music]
a city budget a county budget a state
budget at a national budget are all
markers of what our societies are
prioritizing the u.s. spends 100 billion
dollars every year on policing most of
which comes from local municipalities
New York City for example appropriated
5.9 billion dollars last year to the
police department for comparison here's
what the city allocated for homeless
services health housing youth and
Community Development and jobs programs
the disparities are huge and they echo
in cities across the country like in
Chicago where the policing budget is one
point seven billion dollars roughly
twice the budget of the fire department
Department of Transportation Public
Library and Public Health combined if
you look at these budgets in the United
States what you'll see is that we have
deeply deprioritized
providing people their basic needs
instead we've over prioritized
punishing human beings the emphasis on
policing in the US has led to over
policing and under policing all at once
the police arrest over 10 million people
in a year and the vast majority of those
arrests especially in black and poor
neighborhoods are for minor offenses
like drug possession or drinking in
public that heavy-handed approach is
over policing but when it comes to
violent crime the rate of police arrests
is incredibly low and that's under
policing which leaves communities of
color underserved people believe that
the police are deterring violence
clearly they're enacting violence but
are they also deterring violence and
that's highly questionable a lot of
research suggests that they are having
no influence whatsoever so if they're
having no influence whatsoever on the
phenomena that they're supposed to be
influencing and they're doing violence
what purpose are they supposed to serve
the repercussions of prioritizing the
police over other services can also be
seen at schools in the US 1.7
students are in schools with police but
no counselors and 3 million have police
in schools but no nurses and when it
comes to 911 calls in many cases police
officers are the first responders to
mental health related emergencies
that's important because one in every
four deaths from police shootings are
people with mental health problems
I can literally imagine you just replace
someone with a weapon someone who will
actually sit down on the ground with
them and talk not throw them on the
ground and sit on top of them or lay on
top of them but someone who will take
them wherever they are listen to they're
listening to their situations and then
try to figure out diagnose their problem
police are doing the jobs but other
groups of people and workers can be
doing being tasked with jobs they're not
trained to do is an idea some police
officers acknowledge to every societal
failure
we put it off on the cops a song not
enough mental health funding get the cop
Hamilton not enough drug conviction
[ __ ] let's give it to the cops
schools failed give it to the cops
policing was never meant to solve all
those problems the need to rethink
police budgets has become even more
glaring in the middle of the corona
virus pandemic many have called
attention to the fact that hospital
workers struggle to get personal
protective equipment while thousands of
police officers have riot gear at the
ready for protests
even in response to the pandemic while
many agencies grapple with coronavirus
budget cuts police budgets have largely
remained intact new york city's proposal
for the coming fiscal year cuts just 5%
of the NYPD budget but that same
proposal calls for a 12% cut to the
department of health this is where the
movement to defund the police comes in
it's a push to take the billions of
dollars city spend on police and move
that funding to other services like
housing jobs or mental health care at
its core the idea is to rethink Public
Safety because the current form of
policing isn't built to serve everyone
equally we live in an economy of
punishment we as in black people as
important as in marginal people police
are not used to keep us safe
well we've seen over the last seven
years is black people being killed
humiliated violated sexually assaulted
maimed by law enforcement we haven't
seen it get any better reimagining
public safety in this moment is a matter
of life or death for years reforms like
introducing police body cameras have
been proposed across the country as a
response to police brutality but these
reforms have only added more money to
police budgets even when as studies like
this one in d.c show they have no
detectable effect on police use of force
we absolutely need to try an old law
enforcement accountable but what we've
recognized is all of our accountability
measures up until now have not worked in
the case of Minneapolis since 2016 their
police officers have received body
cameras bias training and have a duty to
intervene policy where other police
officers must step in if they see force
applied inappropriately yet a
Minneapolis police officer killed George
Floyd as three officers looked on this
idea that we could reform an institution
that has a blue code of silence that we
can reform an institution that is one of
the most powerful unions
that is no longer the conversation the
calls to defund the police have been
polarizing and have led to some fears
about how it might affect personal and
public safety how do you defend or
dismantle and keep people safe when we
all dial nine-one-one we need to know
there's somebody coming
you defund the police we're diminish
their ability to police their
communities you're gonna have a war zone
I think we often hear issues of safety
for mostly white affluent people and
after remind those folks that their
safety is predicated on the unsafety of
black people opponents of defunding the
police have cautioned that after cities
like Memphis downsized their police
force there is an increase in violent
crime but proponents point to a major
difference between defunding the police
then and now today it's not just about
cutting police budgets a key part of
defunding is to redistribute those
resources and create better responses to
crime that redistribution would still
fund first responders but put four
cities to rethink what kind of
responders would make communities safer
for everyone whether it's investing in a
new crisis intervention team a mental
health team or social workers in some
cities like Eugene Oregon and Austin
Texas alternative models for safety have
already been put in place to dispatch
mental health professionals to certain
911 instead of the police and putting
money into other agencies like housing
and jobs to help people meet their basic
needs could also end up making community
safer rather than have this some I'm
fearful of someone someone coming to
take my stuff hey can I have a number
that I can call so somebody with some
weapons can come protect my stuff it's
more like if everyone had some stuff and
if everyone had a reasonable existence
they wouldn't be looking for anybody
else's stuff and you wouldn't need to
call anybody black lives matter
activists and local organizers across
the country have been working to defund
the police for years but for many the
calls to defund the police don't stop at
scaling down the scope of what the
police can do it could also be a first
step towards eventually abolishing the
police as we know it you could think
that the defund movement is the gateway
to a broader discussion of
reprioritization one position of which
is abolition the details of a plan like
this differ from city to city but there
is a shared purpose of altering what
Public Safety looks like in the u.s.
defunding the police even at its most
basic will still be a difficult battle
for activists on a national scale one
poll conducted in early June found that
only about a quarter of Americans
favored cutting funding for police
departments but in parts of the country
it's already happening in Denver the
school district has broken their
contract with the police department in
Oakland the school board pledged to do
the same and in Minneapolis the City
Council voted to completely disband its
police department and create a new model
all of these moves can be traced to
continued public pressure and protests
against police brutality protests which
in a matter of weeks brought the slogan
to defund the police into the mainstream
this has been the most tragic three
weeks and also the most inspiring three
weeks we have seen death after death of
black people what are we going to do to
be in defense of black lives that is the
conversation we're asking it's not just
about black lives mattering that's not
enough to proclaim that you have to step
into a new role in protecting black
people and ensuring that their lives are
safe
you
you